welcome to this video and halsey Nita
mm-hmm okay SS layin the Kalashnikov
always wondered about the region of this
name yeah let's see and I didn't really
what is this I just allowed the
transposition to the original trash Nico
right ok so I'm going to play this
Bishop e6 stuff this is a totally
forgotten line but it's not that bad hmm
does he really here you see the snow
stuff here right that's the the main
line and pretty good for white actually
ah poor have forgotten how it is played
something with 94 but I really have
forgotten can you take b7 hmm
hmm
yeah hmm I think he can just take b7 I
mean ok maybe can also do that but I
think he could have taken down ok what
is this I can take here i am on f 2 13
checkmate what is the big idea I don't
don't get it ok and this is that great
yeah maybe maybe it is b5 he is going to
play rook everyone okay if I go put foot
if I go with C 5 here in this position
and then take on c4 you can give checks
maybe that's a perpetual or something
sure I don't know did I have something
better really don't know so queen bee
seven Roxy forth the idea I wonder can
you go queen bee seven look-see for look
f1 rook takes you to check king be one
that I can take on be too many for four
I don't know what but I wonder I mean
does he really have any other move than
green b7 this is kind of curious because
all the stocks totally forced queen bee
7 Roxy for why am I just escaping all
this checks and and win maybe I am yeah
Roxy FOIAs the only move that does make
any sense I believe check into g7 maybe
yeah looks it too right
yeah let's do the hair and now look D 2
with a funny move but yes checks out
lots of them so Luke be too probably and
that's I don't know it's probably not
enough in the long run I have no square
but um I mean he can take there but then
King the age is this soup or what is
this can I just do that would be really
very funny I can't give this checker
I'm not very well developed
unfortunately check check my porn is
hanging the e6 pawn
if I had some time it would be okay
really but that's it's difficult as it
is look see Molly now I know it looks
terribly slow but i think i probably
need night on c5 to block the civil time
morning check
yeah a fourth ah what a shame hmm don't
really know what was going on there I
was certainly interesting I'm not sure I
ever had anything good
check
now you can play probably would be one
or anything like that now that's maybe a
little bit little bit too to chaim
precise but um can take on on f5 okay
yeah still rupee one is probably winning
maybe rook c8 i can i can continue to
struggle somehow yeah this is
threatening made unfortunately
check
King be three wins well failure
necessary complicated what he did but it
win it win so Jamie black resides ja
difficult stuffin I really forgot the
the theory here I don't know how this
played I thought he can just take on b7
and the computer confirms that hmmm hmmm
yeah okay this is I don't know what this
is actually now Luke t2 was winning oh I
didn't have all I don't totally forgot
about that move a very bad game badly
played he played this immediately okay
checks yeah it's a shame that this is
this is really not possible that it
would be funnier check yes is check
check yeah this is it is not enough but
yeah the comp comp gives this but this
is I mean I'm not sure that just a
couple of seconds of calculations
calculation is enough for the computer I
really have a bad feeling em ma'am this
is probably not going to work out at the
end ok and here this is the case where
if I had like just one or two extra
moves then I would prefer perfectly fine
but i don't i don't have this time the
porn hangs on a six I have no moves this
is really not I mean yeah chatter I have
no I'm really lost simply
he played in a somewhat complicated made
a complicated way you had to check it
was it was certainly enough I have no
defense the whole thing wasn't working i
had i totally forgot the theory him I
this is a line that I had played that I
played an internment chasm years ago
really years ago it is not so great but
normally okay to play in a blitz cam
once in a while IRA better have
forgotten the theory this was was an
idea I remember that this was an idea
always 494 I don't know the way it went
it was really bad i mean he could have
could have won easily here with with
rookie too which is really very simple
not quite sure I mean I overlooked it
not sure what what he overlooked I don't
know okay thanks for watching